Good afternoon and welcome
to CAST Conversations
with Jay Scheib and Rian Flynn.
We'll begin with an excerpt
from World of wires directed
by Jay Scheib at MIT in 2018.
A longer version of the
video will be played
at the end of this conversation
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Hunter!
Hunter, what the hell?
What can I say?
You can't sleep here for today.
No, you cannot sleep here.
Dude I think I figured out how
to model barometric pressure.
So let me know if you notice
like your ears popping
or anything like that, all right
extraction phase nobody's here
ready in three, two and one
OH, Wow.
So I'm here and I can see
you but you can't see me.
Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
Hi hey what's up, what
is Stauffer doing ?
Just basic tour
checking some stuff
we haven't done that today.
Oh my ears just popped,
crazy air pressure.
What is she doing
on this channel,
she shouldn't be in there.
[CLATTER] What the
fuck did you do.
You can't-- sweetie are you OK ?
Oh my god, you're
crazy [INAUDIBLE]..
See how savage you are.
It's like completely different.
I know I'm getting and
I didn't change the cold
but it's like here and there.
Oh my god you got to try this.
Eat this drink this,
breathe a little.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Rian Flynn and
I'm an undergraduate student
in Physics and
Theater Arts at MIT.
Today it's my
pleasure to be joined
by Professor Jay Scheib for MIT
casts, three questions series.
Hi, Hi Thanks Rian and
it's great to be here.
My name is Jay Scheib
you just heard.
And I'm a professor of
theater arts, here at MIT.
I just realized that I've been
a professor for theater arts
here now for 17 years, which
is kind of a shocker for me.
It's great to be here.
Thanks Jay.
So to start off
the conversation.
How do you use MIT
and its students,
to prototype and iterate
your off campus work,
and what are you able to do as
a director at MIT that you might
not be able to do elsewhere ?
OK, first question first--
You know I think like,
I think on average
in the old days on average--
I would do, I would do three
or four productions in a year,
in the summer especially I
would make things happen.
And, and doing them kind
of, kind of all over the US,
and primarily in Europe.
And so at MIT my
courses would ultimately
be like an extension,
of my research process.
And so I would develop
classes or seminars
that would kind of align
with whatever productions
I might happen to
have on the horizon.
And whenever
possible, I would try
to develop aspects of
the work on campus,
and I've always found it to
be like a super rich process
to work with students
in that process.
World of wires, the
excerpt that we just saw
was an example of
that sort of thing.
Yeah in terms of
like what I can do
at MIT that can't
be done elsewhere,
that's like a super long list
because it's definitely not
every theater company in
the world where you can sort
of stroll down the hall and
bump into someone from Er
Astro for example.
So being constantly confronted
with entirely different ways
of thinking and ways of seeing
and comprehending the world,
is something that really can't
be duplicated anywhere else.
So that kind of level
of interdisciplinary
is shockingly important to me.
Yeah I've definitely
seen how you've
collaborated with people in
Er Astro or other departments.
And it's been incredible
to see, the work that's
come out of that.
Jay and the two classes,
I've taken with you
at MIT I've greatly enjoyed
the times when you brought
in your professional
collaborators
to teach like many
master classes,
and I've loved
being able to work
with your professional
collaborators
on projects like The Silence.
What is it like to
combine MIT students
with your usual collaborators.
And could you speak to how
you bring these collaborators
into your teaching.
Well-- So a lot of what,
a lot of what I've done--
or obsessed with
over the years has
to do with working in, working
in theater or in opera which
are, which are two like really,
really old art forms, and also
sometimes incredibly
conservative art forms,
art forms with big walls
around them, especially opera.
And, I've always been quite
obsessed with bringing
other disciplines to bear
on these potentially really
conservative forms.
And that means that
often, I'm often
am working with people who have
wildly different skill sets.
And so it's really kind
of an invaluable thing
to bring someone like, to bring
a cinematographer for instance
like Paulina Jurzec who you met.
But bringing her from outside.
I would usually
only work with her
and in various
theatrical productions,
but bringing her
to the classroom
allows everyone to basically
like, get a perspective that's
really different from
mine, and learn new tricks.
You know so I find, I find
that I find that it's just
a really expansive experience.
And following on.
The second part
of your question--
bringing-- you know
incorporating like into work
like The Silence.
So we adopted Ingmar
Bergman's film
The Silence to a sort of live
cinema performance, which
we prototype in like to
[INAUDIBLE] like Fast
and furious weeks.
And it was a mixture of
students and faculty and--
[INAUDIBLE] from around the
country, who participated.
Now there was a time when I
would do this sort of thing,
that where I would
think Oh gosh I
need to like kind of like
protect the students,
like not give them too
much, not like put them
at the center of the
thing, not like not--
put them in a
position where I don't
know they might have
a bad experience,
or feel somehow
like they weren't
able to keep up whatever.
And that's probably true
at some, some schools.
That might be a good
strategy, but I've
found that at MIT
most of our students
like would totally, like not
even like allow that to happen.
So it's been exciting
to just throw people in.
And you know, the results
of that kind of attitude
is that the students
rise to the occasion.
Everyone tends to be incredibly
generous because there's
this like you know
grade like energy
in the room from the
students, and the combination
is I think really
quite electric.
And, and as a
result I've ended up
touring with students
that I worked
with, to places like the
Walker Art center, to Hungary,
to New York really
all over the place.
So, that's really a great,
great symbiotic relationship.
And, and in the end,
everyone gets something from.
Yeah I definitely
enjoyed, acting as camera
operator on The Silence.
When you just kind
of threw me in there
and had me with no
camera experience
just start operating a camera.
That was actually incredible.
You had some experience you
had a little experience.
And by the way, you
shot it beautifully.
Thank you.
Jay in your work you often
experience the intersection
of the real and the virtual.
And given that technology is
increasingly acting as such
a direct performance interface,
how does the cutting edge
research at MIT that you've
been involved in manifest
in your art ?
I think the biggest, the biggest
aspect or the biggest impact
that being at MIT has had
on my sort of engagement
with technology in what is
otherwise a super analog art
form.
used to be kind of
fearless about it,
and to go ahead and ask
questions that at first glance
don't make sense. you know.
Like does it make
sense for an audience
of 2000 people in an opera
house to all wear goggles.
Probably not so we should try.
And I think in a
way MIT has taught
me to think like that for sure.
But it's also given
me an opportunity
to like think in a way
quite incrementally.
So the ways in which I've worked
with cameras over the years
has continually like
grown and expanded,
and, and I kind of like
focus in a studio practice,
on taking one step
after another.
And I'm now in the process
of trying to figure out,
to what degree I can use
volumetric, volumetric
videography in order to create
an entirely different set
some sense of liveness.
I'm no longer using cameras
but actually, but actually
capturing motion and light.
And finding ways to speed
that up to real time.
So in a way like,
I don't think I
ever I probably would
have never even heard
of volumetric filmmaking until
it had become mainstream,
had I not been in
the halls of MIT.
So it's-- it's kind of
a perfect relationship.
Can you speak to any upcoming
work that you're doing that
involves-- you
alluded to it in--
talking about 2000 people
in an opera house--
with goggles on.
Can you speak more to that.
Yeah well I can and
I can't I guess.
It hasn't been, hasn't
been announced because now
everything has been postponed.
But I have-- let's just have
two projects on the horizon,
both of which will--
both of which have
offered me an opportunity
to set a really high
challenge, which
is to find a way
to make use of AR,
VR technology and performance.
So augmented reality,
virtual reality
and some combination
of the two lights,
that we call extended reality.
So I've been sort of toying
around with them, starting
a group called an extended
performance cinemaography
group.
Where we would sort of take
on the prospect of real time
effects processing and--
real time using laser scanners
and in completely different
ways, in order to
develop performances.
And I and I'm going
to bring this research
to bear on, on a couple of major
operas in the next few years.
[LAUGHING] I think
that's all I'm
allowed to say about
that particular project.
But Yeah, so I'm working
on a Wagner opera.
I'm wondering, has
the coronavirus
and its implications
for social distancing
and the use of technology to
be having to use technology
to interact with each other.
Has that influenced your
perception or thinking about
all these techniques that
you use in your work at all ?
Yeah it has, for
sure I think we may
have an imperative in a way
like trying to figure out
how to use the tools that we
have, to bridge the distances.
We do it pretty much
automatically all
the time right.
But, but there's
something about,
there's something
about a live event
that you know I don't know,
does it for us in a way.
Like when you're in a room
with someone who's performing.
It's just a very
different experience,
than if you're say
watching a film,
or even watching a
video conference call.
But somehow, somehow
finding a way
to make technology bridge the
distances is an imperative.
And I can't think of a
better place than MIT
to try to figure that out.
You know we still don't
know when large assembly art
forms will--
come out of the, come
out of the basement.
Like right now we're
all kind of sheltered,
so it's hard to say when
that will happen again.
Like when we're going to have
2000 people in an auditorium.
It may be that these people
that these 2000 people will need
to feel like they're in the
auditorium, and so you know I'm
very excited by developments
in like Olfactory
AR and other kinds of things
which would really give you--
a sense of being there,
even though you're not.
And hopefully without
the depression
when you realize that
you're actually not there.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Remember where are
you, you're in--
where are you -
I'm remote
Being remote right,
there you go.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, I remember you saying
once about how you know,
when you watch sports on TV.
It's a more live,
than live because when
you go into the stadium
and actually like see them,
you're so far away
and everything
seems like, it's not as live
as when you see it on TV.
And I think your
work definitely is
trying to get at that more
live than live kind of.
Yeah somehow, you know
somehow the prospect
of like actually
having something live.
When you're, you're and
amplifying it is quite,
is quite different
when there's no--
when there's no
like there, there
or when the there is scattered
around the world you know.
Because we can put
together a group of,
a group of performers.
And maybe we will in
the fall because, I'll
make a production in the
fall with the MIT students.
And the expectation
is that, well we
don't know where things
will be in the fall.
But in the odd
chance that we have
to be somehow like practicing
social distancing in the fall,
we will find a way to make
the production anyway using
whatever means of,
whatever technologies we
can hack together at the time.
So we'll see.
More live than,
than live, more live
than live even when it's not.
Yeah, thank you so much
Jay for taking the time
to have this conversation
with me today.
And thank you to everyone who
joined us for this webinar.
And thank you to Cast for
giving us the opportunity
to have this conversation.
And now I'd like to turn
it back over to Catherine.
Thank you.
Thank you both.
And thanks, everyone,
for joining us
for this conversation with
Jay Scheib and Rian Flynn.
Please visit our website
arts.mit.edu/from-anywhere
for a wide range of Arts
activities, online exhibitions,
and performances
research and more.
And before ending
this broadcast,
I will play a longer excerpt
from World of wires at MIT
in 2018.
Have a wonderful
weekend everyone bye.
Hey Hunter, Hunter what
the hell, What can I say?
You can't sleep here for today.
No, you cannot sleep here.
Dude, I think I figured out how
to model barometric pressure.
So let me know if you notice
like your ears popping
or anything like that.
All right extraction
phase nobody's
here, ready in
three, two and one.
OH wow.
So i hear and I can see
you but you can't see me
Hi professor Lee am OK.
Hi hey what's up, what
is Stauffer doing ?
Just a basic [INAUDIBLE]
checking some stuff
we haven't done one today.
Oh.
My ears just popped,
crazy air pressure.
What is she doing
on this channel,
she shouldn't be in there.
[INAUDIBLE]
What the fuck did you do ?
You can't.
Sweetie are you OK ?
Oh my god you're
crazy [INAUDIBLE]
That was awesome.
It's like completely
different I don't get it
I didn't change that
much the cold but, it's
like here and there.
Oh my god.
You've got to this.
Eat this drink this.
Breathe a little [CLATTERS]
Professor Lee what are you
doing ?
Are you out of
your fucking mind?
What the hell is going on here?
I don't know, I haven't
figured it out yet.
But what's your guess.
I [INAUDIBLE] the security tapes
but no, nobody's has been in.
Even [INAUDIBLE] you're trying
to sabotage, I don't think so.
[INAUDIBLE]
So these [INAUDIBLE] explosive
get Cynthia or Natalie for me--
your state in five minutes.
This is not acceptable, fix it,
OK five minutes.
Fix it.
OK Five minutes.
We don't have five
fucking minutes, Cynthia.
Oh my god.
Open the fucking windows.
Smells like smoke in here.
Wait does use the--
God damn Cynthia
[INAUDIBLE] I'll
blow your go damn
head off goddamn.
[CRYING]
Look him from here.
I don't see anyone.
[SCREAMING]
Freeze put the gun
down hands where
I can see them, put
the gun down now,
now do it now, gun down
face on the ground.
[GUNSHOT SOUNDS] It's
plastic [BREATHING HEAVILY]
Help, Help we need a paramedic.
Lean in the back, stay
with me stay with me.
You're going to be
fine, I promise you
you're going be fine OK.
Don't worry I'll save you I
swear, I swear, I'll save.
Come on stay with me.
Oh my gosh He's
loosing a lot of blood.
Get the guards, get
the guards come on.
Stay in the way, stay with me.
--about problem and
lungs seems clear.
[INAUDIBLE] unknown
no exit wound.
Hang in there
buddy, stay with me.
Patient has lost consciousness
we administer CPR.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
I need help come on
please, I need help.
Forget it he's gone-
Come on.
It's over.
Goddamn fuck, fuck goddamn
no, no, fuck, fuck [INAUDIBLE]
Stop it.
That was a great
simulation, well
it was unbelievable those--
it was so real holy shit.
Yeah maybe that was a little
bit too weird no, no, no, no
this is exactly where we're
going more real, more harsh
that's what they want and
we can give it to them.
There are a lot of things,
that shouldn't have started up
as jokes.
OK the fact is that
when you finally
succeed at putting
machines inside
of people who find themselves
living inside of machines.
You're going to have to
bring some, some pretty
heavy thinking about
the fundamental nature
of both machines and people.
Oh
I transferred your
consciousness.
That's impossible.
[LAUGHS]
[MURMURING]
I knew, it it's green.
[LAUGHING]
It's possible.
I switched your consciousness
with my husband.
And it worked no it's true.
You know it's like we
hear from a video game.
It's like playing
Grand Theft Auto,
and then realizing that the
Grand Theft Auto car is parked
in your driveway, and the
Grand Theft Auto girl is still
right there, right next to you.
And you can just reach
out and touch her.
Hair, eyes, mouth, neck,
shoulders, stomach.
So I'm here?
[BREATHING HEAVILY]
[THEME SONG]